[Music]
good morning no it's like three o'clock
we're heading to Mount Fuji not really
we're going to the famous got going on I
never remember what it's called it looks
really good I'm excited it's beautiful
weather and spirits are running high
Brenda's really cute right
[Music]
[Applause]
we're getting really close
[Music]
imagine Logan all went on this dream
this same journey when he went to the
forest where on a famous brain right now
look at all the mountain food cheese
what happened to this one does anyone
know
there's no guarantee
salty hmm
look at that slope root very nice it's
about 20 minute walk Ikki months oh
there's so many steps it's gonna be
worth it
how's the view we can do it Marcia
that's it there's monkeys and Boris is
dying
we're almost at Mars yeah that's it 30
[Music]
Wow Wow amazing
oh yeah we gotta take we are at walking
looking for logan paul references what
yeah he's there oh wow it's so brian
show me fuji we're giving him the watch
her gosh oh it's so amazing guys
sorry about the logan references I can't
help it we're going to a 7-eleven in the
middle of nowhere good night god it's
good night
oh you're so mean a sight oh yeah
something to say is that how you say
hello and welcome back to vlog we're
standing in the longest line I've ever
seen in my life for Team Lab and it
should be very exciting
I stuck with a kid we got we got to get
the soft keep walking you box okay so we
just went through the line and there's
another line inside the line we're stuck
here forever
this is so cool I can't speak and where
I asked hey look it's Joey
hey it's totally me what a great block
yeah there's so much to explore
there is a Marzia so he touched the
kanji they will change citizen
what is that what did I do well it's a
flower Danny Joey
it's a tree house water
[Music]
that's pretty dope another room what is
this
knock Jesus Christ man
[Music]
you're supposed to touch where the light
is crossing come on there's another one
how tall do they think we are oh no damn
this is so trippy it's not extend their
look whoa with the ceiling she seems
like moving on is it not if you stare in
the middle there it's weird this is
crazy
whoa oh my mind is getting below I'm
lying it's getting blown
[Music]
whoa well where am i walking whoa ah
don't look that don't like that Wow
Wow
this is so cool weather whoa
[Music]
so surreal looking everywhere there's
something and you look down and it's
just like
it's raining
[Music]
turn a token
we get such a good footage of us you can
totally see everything this is an
Android and Andrew has good quality okay
how is this whoa oh it's you I thought
you were produce where's the stripper
pole
I was tadpoles
no it's tadpoles baby
I knew that well well well what a day of
lights and more lights
it's a trampoline well enemy battle
it's black hole which how where's the
sword let's go slide boys can you see me
at all probably not there we go oh man I
am in the middle of King nowhere I
decided to take a shortcut I'm blown
away where it led me I'm going through
this park but there's no light I just
found this little sign oh my god
found footage of pewdiepies I'm scared
that someone's gonna walk up to me I'm
like looking everywhere it's so creepy
I'm sure this is like beautiful cuz
there's like greenery everywhere but man
I'm scared I just want to make it back
to the station that's all I ask
I'm genuinely it's so cool though I wish
you could see this is giant tree in
front of me that goes right them you
can't see that Kenyan no you can't see
anything cuz Android has the best
cameras there's water to the left of me
so if I take a wrong step
I'm practically screwed basically March
says sick and I decided to go out on an
adventure she sent me out as well
there's like a little shrine here oh I
hope this black screen will do for
footage for now I'm just keeping myself
company at this point I feel really sad
because we came on this trip to figure
out if we wanted to live in Japan or not
and to figure out if it was possible we
meet up with other people there's
someone else oh god there was another
person there he was making me your
noises I'm so scared we made it boys you
don't why do you not see anything
Android fix your camera we wanted to
figure out if we could live in Japan or
not so we met with visa people and we
met with tax people but it's just so so
so difficult that we feel a little
overwhelmed by it we knew it was gonna
be difficult obviously but there's a lot
of things to factor in with not just us
and the dogs and the time and the
housing it's just a big step that I
don't know if you're ready to take or
not I feel like
I really want to do it though I feel
like I don't want to look back in a
couple years and be like oh I wonder
what it was like I wonder what it would
have been like and I think I mean the
unique opportunity to do something like
this and I really want to try it even
though a lot of people you know
obviously it will be difficult so I feel
- a bit sad I don't know because we
don't know what to do basically I made
it I'm alive that was insane
never takes shortcuts ever again I'm
sure it's beautiful but I'm not doing
that again
I was scared I'm really scared I'm
freaked out oh thank god
I'm genuinely relieved okay I made it I
just wanted to show that I am live I am
Alive
[Music]